Also
let's do some introductions if I may so
to my far right we have Kira Keller who
is our commission Services
representative to my immediate right we
have Sue Mullins who is our solicitor uh
our planners in no particular order are
Amy flute Ryan O'Keefe and Sarah Leach
and we have to my immediate leftist
Emily Napier who is our planning manager
Emily I believe you will have a
statement to make
thank you chair my role tonight is to
provide impartial advice to committee
members and to assist members in their
decision taking thank you
fabulous thank you very much indeed
right let's move into the meeting itself
so first item is apologies for absence
do we have any apologies please
yes we have apologies from cancer Iraq
where councilor Adam substituting
marvelous welcome cancer Adam a
disclosure of Interest members do we
have any disclosures councilman Mills
please
thanks Mr chairman
um application six
um on the agenda for shots well
um I'm the County Council for this
um Parish Bernard were you sitting out
on that
um debate Mr chairman thank you okay
thank you very much Council Foreman
uh thank you chair I've received an
email from
um someone on application number six two
two slash 03114 ful I don't know if
everyone else has had it about a site
visit
okay it looks like everyone has uh so we
will put that down as a blanket for
everyone if we can please uh any other
declarations I'll do mine so um on item
number four which application reference
2202 698 ful that's Western house
um I knew the people that did own it I
believe it's been sold um we were good
friends for for some time a long time
ago but we haven't spoken for a while
and I also have one of my uh again a
friend from a long time ago who lives
next to the site but we haven't spoken
to each other about this and I'm here
with an open mind so I will remain on
committee for that item and application
uh so number six on our agenda
application
2203114 ful uh the mount in shots well
um uh I have also received an emails but
I've also had correspondence from one of
our speakers tonight uh and also um a
couple of uh offices as well but again
I'm here with an open mind and will
remain on the committee uh for that
right let's move into oh we've got
minutes next is everyone happy with the
minutes as they're presented in the
agenda pack yes that's lots of non so
we'll sign those later on um let's move
to our first item then which is
application reference
220298 ful Western house and milk Road
in Welford of Avon opportunity officer
is Amy flute Amy as soon as you're ready
it's over to you
thank you chairman
the application site Edge black is an
existing dwelling in Wellford the site
is accessed off Mill Creek Road to the
South the application site is within
wildfoods identified built of area
boundary
the sight edged red is bound by
Residential Properties to the west north
and east planning permission is sought
to retain and alter the existing
dwelling and build four dwellings within
the grounds
a scheme for four additional dwellings
and the retention of part of western
house has previously been refused and
dismissed at appeal the previous scheme
was dismissed on housing numbers housing
mix and harm to a non-designated
Heritage asset the inspector only
dismissed the appeal on housing mix the
proposed layouts and visuals for the
proposal that was refused can now be
seen
The Proposal seeks to retain part of
western house as the central dwelling to
the site to facilitate the development
partial demolition of Western house will
take place
four dwellings and Associated carports
are proposed to be cited within the
grounds of Western house the scheme will
be landscaped retaining existing mature
hedgerows to the north east and west
which act as existing boundary features
between the site and neighboring
properties the existing seven Hedgerow
will be retained albeits where the new
access is proposed
plots one and five will Front millcote
Road and the access road that serves the
site the dwellings will be two bed
Bungalows plot free illustrates Western
house in the form it is is to be
retained
plot 2 will be to the north west of
Western house and plot 4 will be to the
north east of Weston House both are one
and a half Story three bed dwellings all
dwellings will use facing materials such
as brick tile hanging and tiles to
complement Western house
site sections can now be seen which
demonstrate the proposed dwellings are
subservient to Western house
images of Western house are now being
shown the modern single story additions
to the East and the garage
to the north are to be demolished
retaining the main part of western house
on site
the top image taken within the site
demonstrates the eastern boundary and
the site's relationship with number two
milk Oak close the site sorry the bottom
image shows The Wider relationship of
the site with milk close
the site's West and Northern boundaries
can now be seen
um the properties to the rear that can
be seen our Orchard clothes
and these
um images show the visibility display at
the approximate position of the new
access looking in a Westerly Direction
along mill cut road towards long Master
Road and an easterly Direction along
millcote Road
finally these images show views of the
site when traveling west along Mill
Creek Road the relationship of this site
and milk close can be seen the site's
seven boundary can be seen which is a
mix of mature hedging and close boarded
fence
and this image shows the relationship of
the site with milcoat house to the east
of Weston House the existing access is
just in the Hedgerow here
chairman it is not considered that the
proposal will result in unacceptable
harm to landscape neighboring immunity
highway or flood risk chairman the
recommendation is to Grant the
application subject to conditions and
notes as detailed within the committee
report please also note some updates to
the report on the update sheet thank you
Amy thank you very much indeed let's
call our first speaker on this item run
for tonight which who is councilor
Appleton from Wellford Parish Council
good evening councilor Appleton
and welcome
and when you're sat confluent ready to
go you'll have three minutes
um I will give you a 30 second warning
rather than speak over you you'll hear
this noise
I'd be desperate to press that button
um
we are bringing up your presentation now
oh because For the next one fine okay so
whenever you're ready if you press the
button on the right it will go red and I
will start the timer over to you
okay uh so straight in this application
is a variation of design that was
dismissed at appeal
on the 23rd of June of last year and the
reason for dismissal was that
development would not provide an
appropriate mix of dwellings
the option was submitted a new design
replacing two of the three bed
properties with two bed bungalows
the four bed properties become
three-bedroom
this is an improvement however it still
falls short of requirement our 2019
housing needs survey specifies five two
bed Bungalow Bungalows for Market
housing
the appeal inspector considered the
appeal against two other points they
conclude that it was in a suitable
location and dismissed the idea that it
was not a that it was a non-dairy
non-designated Heritage asset
however this is not the whole story a
Common Thread through the entire appeal
report is that the inspector appears to
be lacking evidence
on location for example the inspector
claims no evidence was presented that
the school was oversubscribed however a
simple search for the government school
information website indicates that
Wellford school has a capacity of 250
and that it has 267 pupils
on the Heritage asset question the
inspector indicates that the documentary
evidence is missing
they attach importance to the fact that
Western house is not included on any
local list
the reason for this of course is that
there is no list
and there is no Prospect of there being
a list
when the parish council became aware of
this in January
we felt we had no choice but to pursue
listing Western house ourselves
to this end we have applied to Historic
England to have the house listed
they will make a recommendation to the
Secretary of State or determine on this
matter
Western house is on the edge of the
village an additional four dwellings in
this location is unnecessary
intensification at the Village Edge at
the time of the appeal report 156
dwellings have been permitted or built
in Wellford on Haven this number now
approaches 200.
with an original limit of 84 dwellings
the idea that this is sustainable is
barely credible
moreover
there is no need for development in this
location the district has over 10 years
of land Supply
notwithstanding the overdevelopment of
the village the parish council feel that
listed status is a mysterial
consideration
therefore a planning decision should be
deferred until the secretary of state
has made their determination
many thanks
any questions or will
I was hoping I'll get to press my button
again
you are well in time so thank you very
much for that members do we have any
questions for Council Appleton
councilor Dixon please
Mr African
um obviously you've made an application
for listing can you tell me on what
basis because I don't know well the
house itself individually okay so the
basis is that it has of a local historic
or Heritage interest and it was um it
was built prior to 1940. apparently
those those criteria are enough for us
to put forward a building for to
Historic England
okay Council Curtis thank you just
following on from that do you have any
indication as to when that decision
might be taken I'm afraid I don't I know
it can be quite a long process
um there is a fast access process that
we could try and pursue if that would be
helpful to all on Sunday
I can put that to cancel
okay any other questions
no council options thank you very much
for your time contribution this evening
thank you if you could turn your
microphone off that'd be great thank you
okay we will call our next speaker on
this item who is Miss Amanda stobs
please good evening
so in the same way as our previous
speaker you will have three minutes uh
your 30 second warning you'll hear the
dong uh whenever you're ready
comfortable and good to go the floor is
yours
thank you chairman counselors
goodbye skin
presented in the planning committee in
2021 comprising a housing mix of two
two-bedroom Bungalows two three bedroom
dwellings with reduced scale of
buildings and the retention of the four
bedroomed Western house in all other
respects the schemes essentially
unchanged
I said the previous application was
refused on three grounds but it was
dismissed at Appeal on only one that of
the housing mix
as confirmed in your office's report the
revised housing mix Accords with the
relevant plan policies to which I add
the council's SPD is supportive were on
smaller sites more two and three bed
dwellings are provided such as proposed
with regards to two other reasons for
the previous refusals these were not
upheld by the inspector the inspector
concluded the council's housing Targets
on minimum figures and then the net gain
of four dwellings would avoid an
unacceptable burden on the local
facilities and infrastructure and that
the proposal was in a suitable location
added which The Proposal is small-scale
infill development within the built-up
barrier boundary and has confirmed in
your officers report Accords with a
relevant plan policies
the inspector also concluded that
Western house is of insufficient Merit
to qualify as a non-designated Heritage
asset a matter for the district council
and therefore as confirmed in your
officer's report the Heritage policies
of the development plan are not relevant
notwithstanding the inspector concluded
that in any case the proposed
demolitions would not harm the character
and appearance of the appeal property
in all other matters the planning
committee previously found the scheme to
be acceptable and as confirmed in your
officer's report it Remains the proposed
development would successfully integrate
into the surrounding landscape is of an
appropriate density and scale meets all
relevant design standards including
climate change measures and protection
of neighboring residential immunity
there are no objections from the
highways Authority environmental health
County colleges fire and rescue seven
Trent water and your officer report
confirms the proposals are acceptable in
respect of Highway flood risk in the
natural environment
accordingly the only outstanding matter
of the previous scheme has been fully
addressed and your officer's report has
concluded that the proposed development
is acceptable in principle and Accords
with the development plan and is
therefore recommended approval and we
support that conclusion thank you
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions for Miss Dobbs please
no in that case thank you very much for
your time and contribution this evening
okay we'll call our final speaker on
this item who's cancer purse together
council's gonna come on down
you know the drill you'll have five
minutes uh again I'll give you a 30
second warning with the uh the the noise
in the background and whenever you're
ready come from good to go the floor is
yours
thank you chair
a previous decision by the local
planning Authority accepted that there
is excessive development in the village
and indeed policy cs15 and cs16 were
employed in the recent decision on the
previous application on this site
Wellford has now had 159 dwellings to
June 2022 built or committed though the
parish council tally is 192 granted in
the village with the majority already
built out
in a previous decision the council
recognized Western house as a
non-designated Heritage asset due to its
social history its connections with the
local community and arts and crafts
architecture the proposed changes to
this building would result in the loss
of the Integrity of the original
building
incidentally residents have researched a
bit more the history of this property
via the Electoral records and they tell
me that the house was originally called
solamo and the annex was called solamo
cottage between 1939 and 1950 they were
together known as the women's land Army
hostel because the buildings were used
to house land girls
residents tell me that the northern
Annex was built at the same time as they
made part of the house and is referred
to as a separate address in the
Electoral roll records going back to
1939 because the annex is proposed to be
demolished
this development is contrary to policy
csha and while for the naval
neighborhood development development
plan policy he4 and I quote development
comprising a Heritage asset within the
setting of a Heritage asset will be
supported providing it Concepts or
enhances the conservation area or
Heritage asset
I have asked a full council meeting in
October whether the council at the local
list of buildings or could provide one a
local list of buildings is an important
tool especially in an area reaching
architectural Heritage such as ours the
response from the portfolio order was
that while such a lease could be
produced this would have significant
resources implications if such local
list of buildings were available we can
argue that inspector would have taken
that into consideration in their
judgment because of the lack of local
lists the Welford on Avon Parish Council
has therefore began the process of
listing westerners with historic England
policy states the garden and background
development will only be supported if
the development does not have a
detrimental effect on this on
neighboring properties within the
development to neighboring residency
various concerns about plot 2 and 4. and
plot 2 in particular is a large
two-story house overlooking The Gardens
of one of the properties in Orchard
close this could result in loss of
privacy and amenity for the current
occupiers and if edges are grown tall to
make up for loss of privacy then a loss
of light could ensue and so this is
contrary to policy hul5 of our neighbor
development plan
so we have supported the housing needs
of the council to date but we cannot
continue to do so when there's been
little investment in infrastructure
milcot road is part of the villovision
trunk route it's a very busy road also
there is no proper safe Crossing to
allow families to cross the long
Milestone Road at the junction with
milkot road to be able to walk to school
or to the shop the full pattern long
Marston road is an even dangerous for
prom and wheelchairs for residents with
mobility issues and we have asked
highways to refurbish this if you're
minded to Grant then the whole
pedestrian infrastructure at this
location connecting to the Village must
be reviewed and improved
drainage we have had frequent failures
in the sewage and drainage system in
Walford and Avon and we cannot support
additional residential development until
Essentials repairs and improvements to
this infrastructure have been undertaken
and proved to be working so for all
these reasons the proposal should be
refused thank you
thank you very much indeed members do
you have any questions for our Ward
member councilor Parry please thank you
chair good evening councilor pertigella
I just wondered whether you can advise
as far as the Welford neighborhood
development plan is concerned
um I know you make reference to Weston
House and obviously you've got a
Heritage policy which is he4 is Western
house identified
specifically by name in your
neighborhood in your adopted
neighborhood development plan as a
special Heritage asset
is not specifically mentioned but then
we have lots of grade listed houses as
well and you know they they are not
mentioned either because they're part of
the conservation area but any Heritage
just said now conservation areas reviews
can also bring up new Heritage assets
but if you don't have a local list of
buildings where we can record this
important assets and they can be
important in relation to the social
history of of the location then we we
don't have anything to to go on and now
these the social history of Western
house was researched because the first
application was going to demolish it
completely
I come back
um but obviously Weston house isn't in a
conservation area and it's not listed
with Heritage England you also say it's
not
um identified within the Heritage assets
of the neighborhood development plan
quite often when Villages are doing a
neighborhood development plan if they
feel there is a building
um of security I don't have to push you
for a question please
I just I just wanted to have further
explanations to why Western house is so
important it's it's not mentioned in
your neighborhood development so there
are so if I can answer a counselor Perry
so there are we have a multitude of
grade listed so these are listed
buildings and no no you know we don't
mention them Name by name
um so you know and and also you can find
New Heritage assets while researching
the history of certain buildings which
might not be grade listed so you know
this is this is what we found out we
under connections and the parish council
is now
um you know in in the process of listing
Western house in its integrity
casacrum please
okay this works thank you all right
um
obviously I'll take road safety
seriously with my role at the county
and there's a part where you mentioned
about the footpath and I think it's
mentioned in the report as well on page
20.
um
you know and I'm really supportive of
person
Etc so Road Safety
um it just says in the report that the
county haven't
um
ask for it so are you saying you know it
will be good to have
yeah I'm sorry yeah so I actually
worship County Council officers have met
I think two years ago with um with the
parish council about this food path
because residents have been you know
raising it with with me with the County
council with the parish council and they
did agree that yes there should be work
done on that to make it safe for people
who have mobility issues and so on
um I think they in the report I think he
says that they don't think that the
uh it's it's not
um you know there's no many houses been
built that you would request for the
developer to pay
um to have an s016 contribution with
that but actually you know this is part
of our infrastructure and I mean you
know we want people to walk to safely to
the to the center of a village if you
know and that and you know that thing
that comes is like infrastructure is
always an afterthought
you know housing comes first and then
infrastructure maybe it doesn't even
come we're still waiting for them to fix
the food path
okay we've got any more questions for
our war member please
note in that case cancer thank you very
much time contribution right members we
will move two points of clarification to
our officers has anyone got anything
they would like clarifying Council Dixon
first please
Amy have we I mean we saw various uh
illustrations there of the designs in
the layout Etc have we got a full
frontal view now of Western house by a
photograph of
the property
I was hoping for a street view
you can't actually really see it from
the street because of the Hedgerow so
um this is probably Western houses here
thank you
councilor Adam please
thank you um it was with regards to the
comment from the parish council
um for school places I noticed under
other matters in the report
you raised this but then referenced
other applications
um in 2019 and 21. uh do we have any
more up-to-date uh feedback from County
on on their position on school places
and allocations available in this area
um not that I'm aware of but given the
scale of the development
um the my view is that the view would
remain unchanged I don't know if Emily
has anything to add to that
uh no I don't have anything to add I
think it's worth just pointing out that
in the appeal decision
um the impact on local Services is
something that the inspector considered
and didn't consider
um that given the scale of development
that it was something where this
development would have an impact on on
the local surfaces was in the village
councilor Harvey please I've got three
questions
um
could any tell us something about the
densities
comment has been made by Council
bertigella about overlooking the
two-pronged question are minimum
distances satisfied and secondly how do
the distances on this site compare with
the distances between houses in in the
immediate vicinity
question number one
so in terms of Separation distances the
separation distance let's get my words
out the separation distances all Accord
with the development requirements SPD
um so the um so for example the rear the
rear to rear separation distance
um is if you just bear with me I have it
written down
um ranges from 36 to 45 meters between
built form
um in terms of the density I don't have
actual density figures um to hand but if
maybe this aerial shot will be helpful
so you can see Milko close um which is
to the to the East and you can see how
the layouts of the surrounding built
form relates to the to the development
site
foreign
raised the questions of the adequacy of
the drainage system
I have experience of this problem in my
ward what reassurance can you give that
if this development was allowed that the
drainage system can act chilly cope
so the application
um site is within flood zone one and
we've consulted with seven Trent as part
of the application and seven Trent have
requested
um that we have fouling surface water
drainage conditioned and so obviously
we'll be able to secure that detail and
through further development
fire conditions
thank you and final question relates to
footpaths my understanding is I can
remember a previous case where a parish
council asked that a speed limit being
moved and we were told that that was
beyond the powers of the district
council to attach as a condition is that
the same in relation to for this
particular footpath so in relation to
footpaths highways have been consulted
on the application and they haven't
requested any contributions as part of
their formal response um
um that they have provided obviously
they have recommended conditions I have
made contact with highways in relation
to
um the request that was made to query
about um Footwear contributions
um and the response I had back was an
upgrade is not necessary and would be an
unreasonable request given that the
additional footfall from The Proposal is
quite low
so I don't think it would be reasonable
in this um case to be requesting money
that especially given we don't have the
support of Highways for that as well
thank you very much Council Mills please
thanks Mr chairman actually one of my
questions was about the sewage problem
which has been or trained probably
covered
um I wonder if could you get the um
the the photographer or the slide up
rather of
how the uh
is development is going to look
please
you've got
that's it ah I was so the
then there are no higher than um
nope that's correct so Western house is
in the middle
um so the top image is uh effectively
from um millcote road so the two units
on the Frontage are Bungalows and then
as you go into this site then um the two
additional dwellings to the rear are one
and a half story all subservient to
Western house so Western house is going
to effectively Remain the main sort of
focal point of the site thank you very
much councilor Curtis please
um
I just this pure for clarification on
page 21 you say
um in the report a CMP
is not required or you do not consider a
CMP could you just clarify for me what a
CMP is please it's a construction
management plan I'll just see it that
one thank you very much
okay anyone else have any points that
they need clarifying let's move into
debate who would like to kick us off
Council Dixon first please
thank you chairman
um the case I've heard is that this is a
property which if listed might have an
impact upon whether or not development
occurred around it but it's not listed
and it's not been listed uh by either
the parish in its NDP or anywhere else
as a building of of Worth to date
however
if it had been listed
would what is proposed cause it any harm
now to my mind
what we are being offered is an
opportunity
for Western Health to actually be
prominent and be open and seen
whereas currently it is hidden
so I think the setting having removed
the conservatory and the annex to the
side and opened up the site is an
improvement and sets it off well
so from my point of view
I think it's a exercise and a worthwhile
addition and I would propose in
accordance with the officer's
recommendation that this is granted
thank you very much indeed Council Parry
please
thank you chair
um I would actually like to endorse
councilor Dixon's views I think
particularly the site is not in a
Conservation Area
um as as advised during the presentation
um Weston house is not listed
it is an infill
it is within the built up area boundary
I think it's very welcome to see a small
scale development that includes
Bungalows two-bedroom Bungalows which
are have been identified in welford's
housing
assessment needs as a requirement I
understand they would like to have five
but actually on a development of this
size to have two Bungalows
um don't normally get loads of children
coming to live in two bed Bungalows but
sometimes you can do
um I think also the inspectors views
um that were made at appeal
um you know we are forced down that road
in terms of what was accepted and what
wasn't and whilst I understand
um the reasons why the parish council
perhaps would like to preserve
um the setting of Western we haven't got
a listing and
um I can't see a material planning
reason to refuse this so I'm very happy
to Second councilor Dixon's proposal
lovely thank you very much indeed
councilor Curtis please
thank you
um
I just I I'm afraid I find myself in
disagreement with some of the comments I
think the the annex and Conservatory
as I think has been explained by the
other speakers is do actually form part
of the historic structure of the
building and to lose those would be to
the historic structures detriment and I
just wonder as well as I accept that
although the building is not yet listed
we understand
um that there is an application for
listing currently before Secretary of
State and I My Views are perhaps this
could be deferred until that has had
time to be considered more fully
while I'm on on Mike as well were we
minded to approve I would like to look
at some of the conditions but that I'll
come to that later if I may share I
understood I have a view on your last
point but we'll come to that if
necessary later on cancer Adam please
thank you um I find myself
generally agreement with um casters
Dixon and Parry uh on the development
but I do have remaining concerns over
the numbers which I think is explained
away to some extent within the um
the officer's report and the
inspectorate's decision
but still these leaves sort of a bad
taste in my mouth in terms of how we
look at development holistically I think
there are certainly concerns that have
been raised by the parish council as to
the school places and albeit that
you know they are so again just
discussed within the report are not
personally satisfied that
um that we can say that four four houses
won't have an impact because again we're
looking at a significant number over the
number of houses that welford's in uh
and on that in the inspectors report
it talks about the sort of ambiguous
language saying approximately and around
as a justification for not setting up a
limit but I think if we're talking about
percentages you can say fairly
comprehensively that 20 percent isn't
around
12 percent
uh I don't know I'm
accepting that this won't necessarily be
a strong enough reason to oppose it as I
said I'm broadly in support of the
design as has been put forward in line
with Council Dixon's comments but
the amount of development Welford has
seen isn't something I'm comfortable
with it's something that I'm very
um cautious about putting any further
support to that type of numbers on
if if those comments are all I can do in
in objection to it then so be it I'm not
saying it needs to be more but I can't
let it go unsaid I think but we have to
consider the number the holistic effect
that all these small developments have
and if I don't say it then you know I'll
feel bad about that so
that's it for now okay thank you very
much anyone else want to join in Council
Andrew Serafin please thank you
um I do have concerns with the numbers
of allocation in their National and
neighborhood development plan and they
far exceeded over double now where are
you going to draw the line concerns me
where do you stop at this uh
allocation of numbers which is uh
in my estimation is for exceeding what
is actually needed
thank you thank you Council Harvey
please
um just on that final point that this
country has got a shortage of houses
needs to build 300 000. we need to take
opportunities where we can find them I
think that uh councilor Parry summed up
the the argument well uh uh and I
disagree with councilor Curtis uh that
you can't put things off uh on the basis
of an application which might get
determined one way or another you have
to deal with a case as it's presented on
the facts on the day you did make the
decision so I will be supporting the the
emotion or the decision the
recommendation to to Grant
thank you very much cancer Crump please
again very briefly um yeah I'll take
counselor and just everything's point
and kind of start talking about the
numbers and it is disappointing
um but again we are limited because of
the inspector's report
if we could strengthen any highways
conditions
um I would be happy for that because I'm
concerned about highway safety and I'll
notice they're asking distance as well
and again the school places it probably
is a fair point but again we've not
adding things back from the educational
Authority or requesting any contribution
to section 106 contributions to
additional places so again I think we're
very limited on when we could apply for
so now my three comments thank you thank
you very much last one Council Dixon
thank you chairman just to come back to
councilor Adam's concerns and we I think
we all have concerns because we're all
aware of the infrastructure and the fact
that you know small scales do not add to
it but small scale development small
scale development small scale
developments all have an impact
um
my only thought is that there is a
review of the local plan hopefully the
next local plan will be more specific in
controlling those sorts of circumstances
no more than that German
thank you very much I think I'm just
going to make out what you said then the
cumulative effect does clearly have a
detrimental impact on on developments
we're not here to make decisions on what
could happen in the future in terms of
policy a review is happening we have to
act on evidences presented within the
policy framework that we have already
set
um so we need to bear that in mind when
we're moving forward
um we have a proposal to Grant it has
been seconded now cancer
um Curtis you did mention that you
wanted to talk about conditions so
before I move to the uh proposal
um what exactly did you want to talk
about in terms of conditions
thank you sorry it's been mentioned that
plot two
um is a two-story building my concern is
that the there is a condition to ensure
that before construction is started
that the the levels the ground levels
are adhered to
um there have been has been a previous
instance in my ward with the same
developer where the site was not cleared
and the building levels were actually
about a meter higher than had been
originally improved approved which meant
that neighboring properties were far
more overlooked than had been
anticipated
I'm struggling to understand the
planning justification that it feels to
me like you're making an assumption that
it might be wrong and therefore we're
penalizing
before anything has been done I'm
uncomfortable with that it doesn't come
back to you it's not it would just be
ensuring that the developer were
permission granted
does adhere to the site levels as agreed
that's not penalizing anyone that's
simply ensuring that they comply with
the planning permission
which in this this particular developer
has not let's not go down that line
because it's not our place to decide
whether a developer has or hasn't obeyed
or done what they've said they've done
in other sites we're here to make a
decision on this site let me just get
some advice then I'll come back to you
bear with me
okay
um I think the general consensus has
been that the site itself is fairly flat
pretty much is flat
um in order to justify requiring the
sort of condition you're talking about
we need to have a really clear
justification for it and I'm not getting
one of them in a real clear planning
justification for it I'm not getting
the best one could do is attach
um to the hard and soft Landscaping
condition to include details of the
levels but again I really do need some
form of just planning justification for
it
um
at the moment we don't have one and I'm
very uncomfortable adding that to it so
I think we're going to leave it at that
and move forward there was no other
conditions you were worried about right
in that case we're going to move forward
so we have a proposal to Grant from
Council Dixon uh secondly by councilor
Perry please have a show of hands
footage in favor of granting
turn those against
and abstentions
two so committee therefore results to
Grant application 2202 698 ful Western
house in Wellford upon Haven
okay we will move to our next item which
is application reference 2202 546ful
that is home Farm once again in welfare
unavon our presented compensate is once
again Amy flute so Amy as soon as you're
ready to go
floor is yours
thank you chairman the application sites
donated by the black dot is a group of
poultry sheds the site is accessed off
Benton Road to the north the application
site is an open Countryside location the
nearest dwelling to the site Edge red is
home Farm Planning Commission is sought
to remove the poultry sheds and create
four dwellings
the site has extant class Q approval to
convert two of the poultry sheds into
five dwellings on the site the class key
layout and the approved elevations can
now be seen
if the class queue was to be built out
the blue and orange areas would be
retained by comparison the proposed site
site layout can be seen on the right
hand side which shows the proposed built
form for this application
compose elevations and floor plans can
now be seen the dwellings will be single
story flat roofed with a Gable feature
the dwellings will be constructed from
Red Brick Timber cladding zinc and Sedum
roofs
this image is taken from Benson Road
looking towards the site in a
self-eastly direction the dwelling home
Farm can be seen
the top image is taken from the access
looking into the site in a southerly
Direction one of the poultry sheds can
be seen in the distance and the bottom
image shows a closer
um
image of the poultry shed and you can
see the adjoining poultry sheds in the
background
and finally
um this um
slideshows images of the other poultry
sheds on the site and you can also see
the vegetative boundary treatment as
well
so chairman it is considered that the
proposal is less harmful than the extant
class queue and the proposal will not
result in unacceptable harm to the
landscape neighboring immunity highways
or fed risk so the recommendation
chairman is to Grant the application
subject to conditions and notes as
detailed within the committee report
thank you Amy thank you very much indeed
we will call our first speaker on this
item who is once again councilor
Appleton from Wellford Parish Council
Council often you know the drill so
whenever you're sat comes from ready to
go the floor is yours
thank you very much
right so the applicant is engaged in an
attempt to sort of a planning policy by
attaining a park queue change of use as
a theoretical fallback position first
this to strengthen the case for building
dwellings in open Countryside
seven attempts to do this on this side
over the last 20 years have all failed
because it's a clear violation of policy
six were also dismissed at appeal
the applicant is relying in the main on
a case from East Sussex in which Obama
was demolished in open Countryside to
make way for three dwellings
there are two important differences
between this case and that one
in that case there was only one
agricultural Barn a very large one with
the benefit of part Q
in this case there are three chicken
sheds
however
only two of them benefit from part Q the
third remains an agricultural Barn it
too is scheduled for demolition
further the total footprint of the
cartilage and the barns that benefit
from Park Q is less than half of the
area of the site so what is a remainder
well it's still open Countryside so
building it a developer must satisfy the
demands of policy they do not
can you bring up the next slide please
for a part two to be a material
consideration in a planning application
it must be considered a real Prospect
so what does this mean
paragraph 35 of the Judgment from Lord
Justice lindblong clarifies the position
talking about the case officer he says
he was well aware of the need to take
into account only a fallback development
that was truly realistic
not merely theoretical
the applicant for home Farm has obtained
Park Q permission and maintains that
this is proof the park Q fallback is a
real Prospect
however it is the parish council's view
that the fallback is only theoretical
there is no real prospect that even if
they were converted the chickens could
be made suitable for human heritation
those of us who have seen the sheds have
all drawn the same conclusion
so
there is no real Prospect of the park Q
being real life therefore the park Q
scheme cannot be considered a viable
before back scheme therefore it is not a
material consideration in this planning
application
therefore the application should be
refused
if you wish to question me on this or
any other aspect of the application
please do
thanks for your time thank you very much
indeed well within your time again
members do we have any questions for
Council Appleton
Casa Mills
um I take it this is not being one of
the chicken farm at the moment no and
it's not used for chicken for a good
long time I would say yeah I was gonna
say do you know how long
I don't I've got a figure in my head in
19 years but I would say don't quote me
on that okay thank you
okay any other questions members
night council option thank you very much
your time contribution your patience
thank you
okay let's call our next speaker who is
Mr James Campbell please
name to Campbell is our agent on this
item
first Campbell once again you'll have
three minutes I think you've got an idea
of what's going to be happening so when
you're ready and comfortable to go press
the button on the right it'll turn red
and the floor is yours
so yeah good evening so I'm here
speaking you um as agent uh actually on
behalf of the applicant uh this evening
uh speaking of favor of this proposal
before you
uh the application proposes for high
quality single story Bungalow dwellings
in lieu of an extant class queue prior
approval for the conversion of the
existing poultry bonds to five dwellings
the proposed dwellings comprise a simple
built form with large areas of green
roof and feature Gables
red brick Timber cladding and profiled
metal roofs form a sympathetic material
palette in keeping with both the
regional and agricultural vernacular
as stated in the officer's report The
Proposal provides a 325 square meter
reduction in floor space when compared
to the extant class queue approval
this is in addition to providing further
controllable betterment such as improved
immunity landscape biodiversity net
gains along with a commitment to
providing sustainability and climate
change measures
um
additionally there has been no objection
on grounds of Highways environmental
health ecology or from Seven trends
the fullback position for five dwellings
is extant and therefore considered to
establish the principle of development
on the site despite it being located
outside of the settlement boundary
the relevant appeal case law outlined in
the officer's report describes that the
fullback position is a is a material
consideration which must be afforded
significant weight in the consideration
of this application
a couple of additional points just
following up on the questions asked on
the previous item uh with regard to
school places it's worth noting that the
proposal in front of you is to reduce
the number of dwellings from five to
four
and with regards to drainage we're
looking to control or deal with all of
that on site through the use of package
treatment plants or the like so so we
know further burden on the local
infrastructure
for these reasons and the reasons
outlined in detail in the offices report
I respectfully requested the committee
moved to Grant this application thank
you
thank you very much for within your time
again members do you have any questions
councilor Parry please
hello good evening
um I'm wondering whether you can
possibly answer the question raised by
the parish council regarding the
um the extant permission
um presumably if you've if you've acted
on behalf of the applicant can you
advise
can I just ask how realistic would it be
for them to go ahead with the former
application that has approval as a class
queue
um well I'd say it's a very real
Prospect due to the fact that clearly
invested lots of time money resource
into firstly acquiring the site
professional fees application fees and
you know has it how did they do have an
interest in uh developing the property
it's great to hear thank you
any other questions members
no Mr Campbell thank you very much for
your time contribution this evening
okay let's call our final speaker on
this item who is councilor pertigella
welcome back
okay so again you know the drill you'll
have five minutes I'll press the button
at 30 seconds otherwise when you're
ready it's over to you
thank you so I'm here supporting the
parish council tonight on the issue of
policy um president as we have heard
with councilor Appleton as I said in my
written representations what is proposed
in front of us tonight is of high
quality design
however there is planning permission
which was obtained via the change of
views part Q legislation and what
acquiries why wasn't the change of views
part Q proposal also high quality in
terms of biodiversity enhancing
environmental credentials of the
properties and Landscape
this is a ful application which seeks to
improve on the previous change of views
application but many of the features
that make the planning application
better than the part queue proposal
should be implemented in any case by the
developer in realizing the particue
design
as the planning officer States the
application site lies within an open
Countryside location and therefore the
current proposal does not strictly fall
within the forms of residential
development that are accepted in
principle according to policy a A as-10
or indeed NDP policies hlu-1 and he5
the current plans are not a community
project the site is outside the buildup
area boundary of the village and as
these are no replacement dwellings
as a ful application this will be in
Conflict also with policy cs15 which is
distribution of development
and but this is why we're here tonight
the welfare Donovan Parish Council is
concerned that the president could be
said of using change of views part q and
then putting fuel application in open
Countryside
however our policy as-10 is supportive
of reusable buildings
he prioritized the ReUse of Brownfield
land and existing buildings and so this
application as ful could have been
making use of the established
agricultural buildings it should be
noted by reusing what is already here
there is less embodied energy and
therefore less carbon emissions in the
construction of the dwellings
and this could be a climate change
friendly approach within the context of
this site
and so of course the the change of use
part queue application was granted and
is extant and the principle of five
dwellings have been established on this
site
but I tend to agree with the parish
council they're using a theoretical test
that it could be developed in a harmful
design it's not appropriate because the
design can be improved I think for the
part queue application too
is therefore for you members to look
into the issue of policy strategy and
setting a precedent rather than
theoretical fallbacks thank you
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions for our war member
no in that case Council thank you very
much time contribution to your patients
okay let's move to punch clarification
to our officers does anyone have any
points any clarifying councilor Harvey
please
um could ask Amy
it was councilor Appleton made reference
to a particular case and I'm afraid I I
didn't quite catch it I hope you did and
my question is does it change your view
given the advice you've already written
in the report is question one
um I didn't actually note down the
specific case
um that the parish council referred to
and let me just see if Emily
got it did you
uh no I didn't but I think um the
officer has addressed the established
case law regarding
um the fallback position in terms of the
the two-step approach and determining
theoretical probability and then the
this the weight that you will afford to
that and that's dependent on
um you know whether you feel that the
scheme is more harmful or not um that's
before you so I think that the the
established case law regarding that has
been addressed within the report I don't
know whether that's the same case law
but we're quite comfortable with the
position
fine thank you um and my second question
is that
um Mr Campbell was quite strident
when he said when referring to the
question of weight
and said I must be it must be given
significant weight now if I turn to page
31 the middle paragraph
there's a reference there the fallback
therefore should be considered in the
determination of this application and
given weight
is its significant weight any weight
limited weight what sort of weight
ultimately it's for you as the the
decision makers to decide on how much
weight you you
give to it
and and that's where this sort of the
second part of the test comes in in
terms of whether you feel that the
scheme before you is
um a more harmful or or a better scheme
than the one that has the benefit of of
the class queue already that's already
been established
Council crumb please
I'm just following on from cancer Harvey
there
um I see those two cases regarding case
law
um mentioned
um the ward member mentioned and I was
listening Casper together that um this
potentially would be set in a president
and I assume she was implying that uh
building the urban Countryside if we
weren't going down the class Q
permission
um so am I right and interpreting that
it's sort of like building the urban
Countryside and as we have to assess
each application on its Merit
by allowing this would we be setting a
precedent
as you
know Jesus is on a case-by-case basis so
in this scenario we are in the open
Countryside but the site does have an
extant class Q permission so that is a
material consideration
um obviously every site is different
um so
and because of how the planning system
works there is that option there where
you can apply for class queue
development whether or not developers
choose to go down that route that's at
their own choice
um so in this instance obviously we have
to consider it based on the merits and
what is before us
Council Curtis please
thank you if I can offer some offer some
clarification for councilor Harvey on
page 32 says does say in the report once
the question of whether or not a
fullback position is material has been
concluded it is then for the decision
maker to decide what weight should be
attached so the decision maker is this
committee presumably thank you
I was looking forward to looking forward
to a question then but that probably
could have wasted the debate but there
we are uh anyone else before I dive in
with one note could you bring up the
picture with the blues and the oranges
and what have you
please I think um I think the Parish
Council made the point that uh it's only
the blue areas are being converted and
actually that orange building is
remaining as a chicken shed is that
correct that's correct so it's only the
blue area which has the benefit of the
class Q permission there is no class Q
permission for for barn two so that
would be retained on the site
okay and can you give me an idea of the
difference in floor area between the two
doesn't need to be bang on just
approximate would be great thank you let
me just check the report because I can't
remember off the top of my head so
um the class
um
the proposed development has a footprint
of 930.5 square meters the class Q
scheme results in a footprint of
1255.7 square meters that's with the
retained Barn that is not the subject of
the class queue
okay
got you thank you brilliant anyone else
have any points of clarification
councilor Harvey again on that on that
question then
the class queue permission applies to
the two blue buildings correct and I
assume therefore
that whether the orange building the
third shed is kept or not is that not a
matter for the the owner
there isn't an application for the
demolition of Bantu so volunteer
should
should obviously be be retained
um
if the owner wishes to remove that in
the future
um then they there is a prior approval
process which you can go through for the
demolition of buildings
indeed
um anyone else before cancer Dixon
please
thank you chairman I was just wondering
what the amenity space was on the class
queue because I'm assuming that the
whole of the site is becoming amenity
space for the new development if it is
approved
can you see the um green area
around the blue
It's like because of the nature of class
cues there the cartilage is limited and
it's obviously not to exceed the size
the footprint of the size of the
building so it is quite tight
and we've been and the whole site
if we approve it it will become
cartilage as such hence removal of PD
rights
it's um so yeah by by comparison they
will have larger the dwellings will have
larger cartilages and I think I have
recommended that PD rights um schedule
two part one class A B C D and E are
removed and the the reason for that is
effectively because obviously the class
queue is the material consideration
that's the fullback
um
obviously we are in the open Countryside
the justification if members were minded
to go with this recommendation is if if
you did go down that route the
betterment of it so obviously it's to
retain pedi removal to retain the
character into sure we don't have
unacceptable development in an open
Countryside location
okay
are we all good to go to debates let's
do that who'd like to kick us off
I'm going to point a finger in a minute
who's it going to fall to councilor
parry's already put her finger up thank
you
I'll come in here
um I was delighted to hear how the
applicant's agent was extolling the
virtues of the class Q
um permission saying how wonderful it
was really or inferring how wonderful it
was
um
I think it would be great actually as
part of the character of the place if we
we kept class Q as it as it is
um I will I will wait to hear how
everybody else feels but I think this
particularly Wellford is very keen to
keep the heritage of a lot of its
buildings so I think
um the development of this into the
class queue would be
would would be part of the heritage of
help of Welford so I'm I'm inclined I'm
inclined to refuse this application
because we've got such a brilliant
planning application for the class queue
um but apparently the applicant is
really excited about so but I'll have to
think about a good planning reason to
refuse it I'll wait to hear what
everybody else says
right uh thank you very much Council
Parry
I'm going to point my finger to that
side of the table next time I think
councilor Kendall
yeah I'm just yes I'm gonna think about
Council apparently caught me off guard
with that um okay
um I think I I think I disagree to be
honest with you Council Perry I'm sorry
I think what's there at the moment I
don't find it although incredibly
important in terms of its Heritage asset
to Welford I don't think it's
particularly attractable I think
I I hear the argument about the fall
back
and I think it makes sense I think
what's proposed is better and I think
probably one day we'll look back and
think well actually it's a very nice
development that we approved and
probably was the right thing to do so
with that I'll propose that we Grant the
uh the uh Grant permission
Council thank you very much indeed
Council Adam Nick
thank you chair unless councilor Perry
would like to Second
um I will thank
thank you very much Council Harvey
uh thank you Mr chairman um I am very
keen to ensure that we're possible and
applicable as10 is observed and that
building in the open Countryside is not
allowed however
um we're not in that position here with
this application
um
I
I think councilor Perry has taken the
tongue out of her mouth out of her cheek
so far given what she said but I have to
say in terms of design and this this
Authority
um
being Keen to see good design uh the
extent permission
um does not strike me as good design he
maybe have been granted and permitted
but if I use the word barracks
um I don't think I would be very far
from my impression
but being being
I'll take the
tongue out of my cheek now
um
I do think that the the design of the
proposal for four houses uh is better
than the extant
um I'm reluctant to come to that
conclusion in in an emotional sense but
um technically having had experience in
my own ward of classic cues and and
housing developments
um I can well understand why the officer
has come to her recommendation and I I
I will be supporting
thank you very much Council Dixon
thank you chairman
um
yes I uh I like everybody else around
here I think is a situation whereby I
think we're minded that the the scheme
before us uh has architectural Merit
over the class queue
um the likelihood of class Q being built
yes we are suspicious possibly
um but what I would like
to understand in the future
is when the case officers are presenting
us with case histories
that
they are certain and can confirm to us
that the cases that they are looking at
are of similarity so that when an
inspector has said I give weight to that
and that then becomes the case law that
we're looking at
are they referring to a site which was
in an urban area
were they referring to a site which was
in open Countryside
Etc because I think it might be
interesting but what I'm just asking you
once I don't disagree with what you're
saying I don't think it's this is the
place to be discussed and that I think
we can take that offline the reality is
what you're saying is you're you are
broadly supportive
um and in the interest of having no one
trip over the tongues in their cheek or
open their mouth and putting their foot
inside it I think I'd like to go ahead
to the vote so it's been proposed by
cancer Kendall seconded by councilor
Eden could have a show of hand slaves in
favor of granting line with officer
recommendation
oh and that is all but one and those
against
and abstentions one of
and one so committee therefore resolves
two Grant application 2202 546 ful home
Farm in Welford on Avon
um we have been going for an hour and 15
minutes
um I certainly need a very quick pit
stop so we will take two minutes and
we'll be back
foreign
okay ladies and gentlemen thank you for
that brief interlude um so we are going
straight into our next application which
is uh application reference 220311 for
ful and
2203115 LBC that is the mount in
shotswell our percentage officer is Ryan
O'Keefe Ryan as soon as you're ready
it's over to you
thank you chairman the mount is a grade
two listed dwelling located centrally
within the village of shotswell
the application is for planning and
listed building consent applications to
um for alterations and extensions to
existing and still around buildings
um located towards this end of the
application site which French Chapel
Lane going down to Middle Lane
as mentioned the application is fully
retention
conversion and some new builds to
existing out buildings in this location
on this plan here
the plan in red shows the modifications
and new build to existing and new
structures
and the blue shows retained
structures in this location
this elevation shows the end elevation
of the amp buildings looking
down Chapel Lane along where my arrow is
pointing here
this is looking at the front looking on
from Chapel Lane into the application
site so at the bottom you can see
um the Gary structure the boundary
wolves
and obviously the proposed showing the
alterations and new build on this
elevation
coming down Chapel Lane and towards
Middle Lane
um
the alterations are
from the garage and a new section of
built form on this corner
and
this is looking into the application
site
um
as indicated along here
owing to the position of development
just
this is obviously a photo taken looking
down at Chapel Lane with the application
the site on the left hand side the
existing garage here the two access
points into the mount and some of the
boundary Walling
this is a view looking up Chapel Lane
and down towards Middle Lane
and the corner where the majority of the
development will occur
and this is taken from Middle Lane
looking back up towards Chapel Lane uh
towards the application property and
where the development is proposed
and this is again looking back up Chapel
Lane
um
foreign
officer recommendation is to Grant
uh playing commission Fuller development
and approve listed building consent for
the development in front of you subject
to conditions
right thank you very much indeed let's
call our first speaker on this item who
sorry about that my machine just broke
uh which is annoying because it's brand
new I'm glad you're here uh okay so um
once you're comfortable and ready to go
you'll have three minutes again I'll
give you the 30 second warning through
the the Bell uh whenever you're ready
press the button on the right on the
floor is yours
Parish Council objects this proposal and
register's dismay at the way this has
been handled not only have we been asked
to withdraw our objection twice by the
case officer but there's been an attempt
to disqualify our objection bought by
the ward member had this been successful
then our residence objections would have
fallen away and not come to this
committee a crucial part of determining
applications is the case officer's
assessment on the street seeing an
impact on neighbors yet requested
paperwork has not been forthcoming we
were asked not to share the agent's
rebuttal with residents however it
appears from the office report that
these are one in the same a virtual word
for word copy and paste shotswold is
situated on the Steep side of a valley
the land Falls away sharply in this part
of the village which is the oldest in
the settlement this Narrow Lane is
blessed with many listed buildings
including our grade two Star Church in a
Conservation Area the importance of
intervisibility between Heritage
buildings cannot be understated and it
is an integral part of the character of
The Village the proposed new double
story buildings will see an overpowering
claustrophobic effect on surrounding
homes and resembles a fortress and I
think like the conservation report which
remarked on its openness and emphasizes
the views across the village as being
important
the amount listed in 1987 is already a
substantial building complete with a
side extension in the 40s this may well
have been a small holding but the
purpose no longer exists and most of its
buildings were demolished pre the 1970s
demolished not because of the condition
but to open up the site and give light
to the Lane enhancing not detracting
without exception all the Neighbors in
the lane have registered an objection to
the proposal impact on the old chapel
suffering most significantly we note in
the agent's rebuttal of photograph taken
from Google Earth in 2009 stating that
the tree was closer than the proposal a
tree can be felt a solid wall cannot an
up-to-date Google image reveals that she
had long since gone Fairview was also
similarly dismissed displaying little
knowledge of the site as there is a
patio area in the back Garden which will
be directly overlooked and overshadowed
by these imposing buildings and if
successful both these properties will
have to rely more on artificial light
the old farmhouse sits above the mount
and will have the potential for glare
from solar panels and loss of light in
their main living area the agent rightly
states that the Heritage buildings have
been altered but they've also been done
sympathetically external Heights remain
the same a caveat in the application
already considers alternate use we know
the officer's suggestion of conditioned
ancillary use but with respect this is
rarely enforceable and you can live in
an ancillary building
given as Stratford has no policy on
Airbnb then there's nothing to prevent
this either the council is not opposed
to change but impact of such change has
to be sympathetic not detrimental to its
neighbors a site visit would have been
welcomed as photographs cannot
adequately portray the narrowness
steepness and quality of what already
exists and the effect on the homes of
our residents down Chapel Lane
which thank you very much indeed uh the
one on the right the one that's
currently read will turn you off
that's the one
um that little Bing by the way was your
30 second warning and the good news is
despite the fact that we did that you
still finished within three minutes
anyway so you were spot on well done
members do we have any questions
um councilor Kendall first please it's
not actually a question it's just that
it's come to my attention that I I do
know this as the speaker but I do come
to the application with an open mind but
it's a declaration of Interest I need to
register at this point very good we will
duly do that cancel Curtis please
thank you
um
you you had a lot to get through so
forgive me um but at the very beginning
you alluded I think you said that the
officer had asked the parish council to
withdraw your objections and you said
something else after that which I also
didn't quite catch could you just give a
little bit more clarification on that
point please
um yes indeed the the case officer did
ask us twice to withdraw our objections
which is probably very unusual and the
ward member
um tried to disqualify our objections so
that it didn't come before the committee
check I just did the case officer give
any particular reasons why they should
why the parish council should withdraw
its objections um I'm just gonna I'm
gonna hold that there there's it's not
uncommon for a case officer to request
or not request suggest that um an
objection could be removed I know it's
happened in my ward it doesn't have to
happen people don't have to remove them
and clearly that's what's happened here
we are giving the thing a fair hearing
the whole application Fair hearing by
being here but it's not uncommon
through the thank you for that
clarification but would the in in that
instance would a case officer not give
some reasons why they would be asking
the parish council to withdraw
my my issue with pursuing this line and
feel free to do it outside of this
committee is where we are now going down
a procedural route
which takes us away from what we're here
to do what we're here to do is to listen
to the evidence that is placed before us
and make a decision on the planning
application based on the evidence within
policy
we start to muddy the waters when we
talk about what has and hasn't happened
outside of this room we have a report
that has been written by our case
officer here's a professional planner
and we now have to determine based on
the evidence it's either presented by
our speakers or by our officers how we
want to determine the application
thank you I think this is something to
pursue offline I would suggest that you
do it offline thank you no problem
uh I saw did I see constant Crump is yes
just a very brief question hello Council
Ingram I've just checked on the parish
council website just to make sure I've
got the right right names Etc
um just at the meeting
I just asked was it a unanimous decision
by the parish council to to object
yes yeah thank you
councilor Harvey please
um I wonder I'm trying to establish in
my own mind
in the year in which the mount was
listed as a list of building what was on
the site
because over the years it seems to have
changed could you help me out with
establishing a clear picture please
I can indeed I was born in
Charlottesville so I remember it well in
1987 it was as it's existing those
buildings weren't there
it's just just the the sort of perimeter
wall
and the garage
okay any other questions for Miss Ingram
please Council Enterprise
oh sorry no
there's clarifications after
okay okay
it's getting confusing already
any more questions for our counselor
Parish Council no councilman thank you
very much for your time contribution and
your patience this evening
okay let's move to our next speaker who
is a Miss Charming Heritage please would
you like to make your way forward
[Music]
you did all possible for me and you are
firm weather in the right order
not really no um could you grab could
you would you mind sitting down really
we should have the microphone on when
you're speaking so just bear with me a
second what I speak to our officer and
make sure that we have photos ready
just bear with me we're just going to
make sure that they are vaguely in the
right order
in the interest of making sure this runs
properly and a fair hearing is given can
I ask that I take your phone the
pictures are in order on your phone
I'm gonna we're gonna go through these
and just double check that they are not
because what we've done obviously they
came through on an email just as jpegs
they've been dragged from that onto the
save file so that we can show them
tonight but we have no idea if they've
remained in the same order in which you
sent them or indeed if the order you
sent them was the order that you want
them so I'll take it from you we'll
number them and then we'll come back to
you and forgive me members of the public
watching
right so we're going to have the first
four quickly after each other and then
in order to move to five six seven eight
you'll just give us a quick nod okay now
you have three minutes the 30 second
warning will be that carry on talking
and I'll let you know when your time is
up when you're ready the floor's yours
thank you chair I live in the old chapel
across this Narrow Lane which measures
just 3.2 meters
directly across from the mount
we live on the side of this hill
which Rises sharply south from our
property towards the mounts this means
that any development in this corner of
their garden and if you stay there for a
moment please would have its Foundations
at the same level as our first floor so
from this Photograph you can see the top
right hand would be completely
obliterated by the proposed building
this objection therefore falls into four
parts bygone usage massing loss of light
and loss of privacy
looking at your own guidelines this is
development requirements SDC section
four I can only presume that the case
officer has given his support due to
this proposal on the basis that the
intended buildings recreate historic
farm buildings which as we've already
heard haven't been in existence for over
50 years it would be ludicrous surely
the consent sought as explained by the
applicants is to build a new home gym
and an office Etc
50 years ago our house the chapel was a
place of worship it was used twice a
week for religious services
for the last 25 years it's been a
dwelling with habitable rooms on the
first floor which will be directly
overlooked by windows in the proposed
development which will be just 7.5
meters from my upstairs window certainly
not a distance in accordance with your
own guidelines
talked about the furview already the
garden and the patio will face the
Eastern side of this structure at a
distance of just 10 meters given the
massing issue the fact the plan
structure
is a steep Bank from their property
lights will be blocked considerably from
their kitchen Diner as well as from
their Garden they like us would
experience this kind of fort-like
structure which given the gradient of
the Hill would have a perceived impact
much greater than its actual size it
would be imposing overbearing and simply
claustrophobic for us
the next one please the chapel has just
one bedroom box room
and one large bedroom
due to the quality of the daylight
through this south facing window so it's
the only window that's facing you at the
moment the bedroom is used as a sitting
room and a study during the day this
particular photograph was taken at two
in the afternoon in January if you can
imagine a line running horizontally to
the right from the Shadow on this
Photograph you can see immediately how
light would be blocked my husband's 78
now asthmatic uses this room every
afternoon and particularly during the
winter when it's the only room with
quality light according to your section
F guidelines light to internal spaces
certain assessments have to be carried
out regarding light and function of
internal spaces these haven't happened
since nobody has visited my home thank
you Mr chair
thank you very much indeed bang on your
time members do we have any questions
from his Heritage please
no in that case massage thank you very
much for your time contribution to your
patience this evening
okay let's call our final speakers of
the evening who are Miss Swan our agent
and Miss ingers sorry miss ingerson our
applicant
good evening to you both now miss one
I'm going to assume that you're going to
be doing most if not all of the talking
and Miss ingerson is here for questions
is that correct
marvelous in that case you I think you
know the drill you've got six minutes
we'll get them up for you now
we will get them up for you now
um You will have six minutes once we've
got the slides up and you're happy and
ready to start you may I will again give
you a 30 second warning before your time
is up
okay good evening chairman members and
officers I'm here with the applicant Mr
ingerson to my left to give you a little
more background information about the
proposals before the committee this
evening Mr ingerson has lived at the
mount for 31 years he's acutely aware of
the special character of this part of
the village and the need to ensure that
any development is undertaken
sensitively both in terms of its
physical appearance and the potential
impact it will have on his neighbors
he has a number of reasons for proposing
the changes to this corner of the site
foremost amongst these is the fact that
there are physical defects affecting
existing structures which need to be
addressed if this part of the
residential plot is to remain safe and
usable there's an existing flat roof
garage which is leaking and collects
huge amounts of water on its roof every
time it rains the garage has been there
since the 1970s and is in daily use and
that's the building that's already
directly opposite the chapel there are
also issues with the part of the long
wall along the southern boundary
opposite Fairview
this is a remaining element of the range
of barns that stood on the site until
the 1970s if you look back at my photo
one
you'll see those barns forming an L
shape if the officer can highlight those
until last year a large silver birch
tree stood on the highway Verge just
outside the boundary opposite Fairview
photo two please
its roots were damaging the base of the
wall and it was removed by the highway
Authority last year works are now
required to ensure that the boundary
feature remains safe and stable in the
longer term you can see the Tall Tree
there that's now gone
Mr ingerson would also like to make the
corner of the site safer by reinstating
the missing section of barn wall that
historically ran right around the corner
this is where a greenhouse is currently
located
the internal corner of the garden is
only enclosed by two shallow courses of
stonework no more than 30 centimeters
high with a very steep drop down to the
road immediately Beyond this makes it
hazardous if children visit the property
the proposals will rectify the
structural problems would provide better
enclosure to the site and would create a
home office and fitness room that would
be attractive ancillary spaces for the
occupants of the mount to use
they would recreate the balanced
historic Courtyard setting of the list
of building the property and would
visually improve a corner that currently
looks very neglected internally in
within the site it's also proposed to
replace the existing asbestos cement
roof over the small storage building
with a new roof and installed Timber
Gates across the access Drive
going back to photo one the historic
photo
Mr ingerson's initial thoughts were to
fully replicate the form of the original
Barns and create more extensive
accommodation than is now proposed he
approached the conservation officer for
pre-application advice in 2019 the
conservation view was that the
reinstatement of the walls of the barns
was appropriate together with a limited
extent of pitched roof to reflect the
form of what had previously existed a
full reinstatement was however felt to
be too large and dominant as surrounding
properties had changed in the
intervening years we fully recognized
that as his planning advisor we also
looked at the relationship with
neighboring properties and felt that a
flat roof design that was no higher than
the existing garage was the best option
opposite the old chapel to minimize the
impact on this neighbor's first floor
window and ensure that the councils
adopted 45-25 degree rule to preserve
light was respected the current plans
have taken both conservation and
planning advice into account much of
what is posed has a flat roof to reduce
its vertical impact beyond the site
moving on to photo 3 the main pitched
Reef section opposite Fairview would be
over 12 meters away from the kitchen
window behind a tree which Still Remains
within the Verge that's 44 I think if
you can go back one
can we pause while we get the correct
photo
the trees on the left
photo 4 shows the edge of the driveway
to the mount on the extreme right of the
image and illustrates that the
development would be at a much lower
level than the neighboring houses
further up the hill the photo also shows
the tight Arrangements of buildings and
walls that characterize the conservation
area and the fact that both these
neighbors uphill have increased the
level of enclosure around their own
Gardens using fencing rather than more
traditional stone work which Mr ingerson
is proposing to use we're aware that
neighbor objections have been lodged on
the basis of possible future uses of the
building and on Highway grounds we'd
like to stress that the accommodation is
solely proposed for ancillary use and
the applicant is fully aware that
planning permission would be needed to
use the space as independent
accommodation this isn't what is
proposed in these applications it's
ancillary space and officers are
recommending a condition to control the
use going forward the applicants happy
to accept such a condition as long as
any business restriction doesn't
preclude the office being used for home
working purposes by the occupants of the
mount themselves
as the space would only be used by the
occupants of the mount there'd be no
more traffic using the lane than there
is now and there's also plenty of space
for construction vehicles to park within
the site during the construction phase
of the buildings
there's no Highway objection to the
application
the building would be of stone
construction to match local materials
and would incorporate sustainable energy
features including solar panels these
would be fitted to the flat roof behind
a low parapet wall at the top of the
walls so they're hidden from view from
the road overall we feel that the
development would recreate the historic
form of the corner of the site and
improve its appearance within the
conservation area it meets the council's
technical standards in terms of impacts
on neighbors resolves current structural
problems and would provide the property
with more flexible living space we
therefore ask you to approve the
applications which have the support of
the conservation officer the planning
officer and the ward member thank you
chairman
this one thank you very much indeed uh
spot on your time as well well done
members do we have any questions for
either our applicant or agent cancer
Services hello there
um the historical footprint is this new
development any bigger than this
historical footprint or is it the same
it's actually smaller if you can go back
please
yes
sorry Miss Thing If you're going to
speak if you wouldn't mind turning your
microphone on they're quite sensitive so
you do need to be talking at the
microphone please it's not on uh it's
flashing at the moment
try again try the right back there you
go you're on okay right okay what you
see there
um that L-shaped structure is about the
same size as the monk which is at the
other end of that courtyard what we are
putting in is probably
one has to be very careful now 30
percent of the size of that
no more
so it's much smaller okay thank you
problem thank you
do we have any other questions I keep
seeing people twitching I'm not sure if
they're twitching to get my attention or
if they're just twitching no other
questions no in that case do you both
thank you very much for your time and
contribution and your patience this
evening
okay and let's now move to points of
clarification does anyone have anything
they would like clarifying
no jolly good let's move into debate who
would like to start us off and debate
councilor Dixon please
whether or not my comments will now be
supported by others I do not know
but
when I look at photographs I always find
that one of the hardest things to
actually glean is the perspective and
ascent and descent
we are advised that this is a hilly area
I do not know shot as well but to my
mind it seems to be all about Street
Scene and the impact of high walls on
neighboring properties and the proximity
of properties to the proposed buildings
so I am going to propose a site to visit
on this one because I don't know shot as
well I don't know if others will support
that or not German
based on the twitching I think I know
the answer councilor Parry please thank
you chair
um I'd actually written down here site
visit I don't feel comfortable about
making a decision on this application
this evening
um we've heard about the variables of
the the the hills
Etc I think this is a classic
example
um where we need to go and have a look
at it ourselves I'm I am familiar with
shots well and it is sort of up and down
Dale
um and I don't think we're being fair
to
anyone unless we defer this application
in the interests of a site visit thank
you chair
okay I saw lots of other people putting
their hands up and I think to say the
same I've can see them all nodding that
it is so I just want to confirm cast
addiction did you propose a deferral for
a site visit
yes chairman thank you and that has been
seconded by councilor Parry lovely thank
you councilor Harvey please
um I will support that but I do want to
make another point which I think is
important
um the officer has very helpfully in his
report
quoted the entirety of section 66 1 and
I draw attention to it
um because it says that we as the
deciding Authority uh are under a duty
because we shall have special regards
not just regard we shall have special
regard to the desirability of preserving
the building or its setting or any
features of special architectural or
historic interest which it possesses
that is half of the argument the other
half of the argument because that that
refers to the listed building
responsibility that we have but we also
have a Conservation Area responsibility
which is set out in section 72 one of
the same act where it imposes upon us an
obligation to pay special attention not
just attention but special attention
shall be paid to the desirability of
preserving
or enhancing the character or appearance
of that area
and I think those are two
important considerations we should bear
in mind when we are undertaking our site
visit and my final point is that in my
view what is what the listed building is
is what it was when it was listed in
1987.
okay thank you very much um I'm going to
see no one else wants to speak we have a
proposal to defer for a site visit uh
could I have a show of hands for those
in favor of that
I believe that is unanimous so committee
resolves to defer application now I just
want to be clear that was for the ful
I'm going to assume the same for the LBC
same for the LBC councilor Perry yeah
could have show of hands again
thank you okay so committee therefore
resolves to defer applications
2203114 if you will and uh
2203115 LBC uh for the reasons given so
essentially a site visit marvelous let's
move to our final application of the
evening
which is application reference
2203268 ful that is the realtor in uh
Henley in Arden
um our presenting officer will be Sarah
Leech as soon as we've had a changeover
so bear with us
okay so our presence conferences that is
Sarah Leech Sarah over to you
thank you chairman good evening
The Proposal is Seeking a retrospective
planning permission for a wooden pergola
the application site is located to the
southeast of Henley in Arden the site is
located the site is on the is to the
north of Warwick Road as indicated by
the black dot on this plan
the site is located within Greenbelt and
to the south of the site is a grade two
listed building called the thatch which
is indicated there
the application site is on the outskirts
of Henley and Arden and is surrounded by
a mixture of fields and some Residential
Properties as seen on this aerial
photograph
here we have the site plan showing the
sighting of the pergola within the rear
Garden the pergola is within five meters
of the dwelling
and these are the elevations
here are some photographs of the wooden
pagola there is also limited views
public views available of the site
officer's recommendation is to Grant
this application subject to conditions
Sarah thank you very much there are no
speakers so has anyone got any points
for clarifying no would anyone like to
start us off and debate I will I'm going
to propose that we Grant the application
because I see no reason not to uh
counseling Crump I will second The
Proposal marvelous anyone else no okay
could have a share of handful those in
favor please
that is unanimous marvelous thank you
very much committee resolves to Grant
application 22.
zero three two six eight ful
um I assume we have no urgent business
no in that case uh thank you very much
members members of the public everyone
that's contributed officers particularly
and we'll see in a couple of weeks time